المترجم: Arij Amara
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
السلام عليكم
الكثير من الناس
عندما يسمعون عن الڨحاف لأول مرّة
أو حتّى عندما يزورون صفحته في الفايسبوك
تتكون لهم صورة في خيالهم
في أغلب الأحيان، عكسها هو الصحيح
وهذا شيء لا يزعجني
في النهاية من يريد يفهم عليه أن يتابع
ڨحاف تونسي ليس أنا. ڨحاف تونسي هو شخصيّة
هو الكثير من الأفكار و المواقف
فلسفة كاملة، صعبة قليلا
و تستوجب الكثير من الوقت و البيداغوجيّة
كي تصل و تُفهم
كلمة ڨحاف تعبر عن واقع يعيشه جزء كبير
من الشباب في تونس و في العالم
واقع البطالة و قلّة المال
يعيشون هذا الواقع كمأساة بينما
يرى فيه الڨحاف طريقا للسعادة و الحرّيّة
و من يريد أن يفهم عليه أن يتابع
ڨحاف تونسي هو شخصيّة أي
شخص يمكن له أن يتقمّصها
سواء كان بصفة وقتيّة أو بصفة متواصلة
و يمكن له أن يسافر على طريقة الڨحاف
أو أن يعيش على طريقة الڨحاف
هذه المفاهيم أردت أن أكون أنا (إلياس)
أول من يطبقها و يجربها
كي أكون قدوة، كي أفتح الطريق
بدأت بتجربة في آسيا, رحلة دامت سنة و شهرين
بمصروف لم يتجاوز 100 دولار في الشهر
ثم عشت تجربة في القارّة الأمريكيّة
سافرت فيها مدّة عام
من دون مصروف تقريبا طبّقت
مفهوم العمل بلا سوم مفهوم حكيت عنه من قبل
و اليوم سأحكي عن تجربة عشتها في تونس
تڨحيفة تونسيّة
رحلة على طريقة الڨحاف قمت بها في تونس
السنة الفارطة
و كانت على دراجة قطعت فيها
مسافة فاقت ال1000 كلم و دامت 35 يوم
بدأت من حي الغزالة في أريانة
و هي المكان الذي كبرت فيه
ثم عبرت ولايات أريانة, تونس
بن عروس، زغوان، القروان
سيدي بوزيد، قفصة، توزر، قبلي، قابس، صفاقس
وصولا إلى الشابّة أرض أجدادي و هي المكان
اللذي أريد نعيش فيه، في ولاية المهديّه
الرحلة كانت على دراجة لا أعتبرها
إنجار رياضي أبدا. لا أعتبر نفسي رياضي
لم أكن أحمل لباس رياضي
لم تكن لي خوذة، كنت أرتدي لباسا عاديا
دراجة بسيطة جدا، عادية، مكابحها لا تعمل
أتنقل ببطء
عليها حمل ما بين 15 و 20 كلغ
أكل و لباس و لوازم التخييم و ماء
بالنسبة لي الدراجة هي بكل بساطة وسيلة نقل
وسيلة نقل نظيفة
لا تلوث و لا تستهلك طاقات جوفية
وتعود بالفائدة لصحتي و لجسمي
أحبها، تعطيني إحساس بالحرية و راحة البال
عندما أسافر
أعيش المكان الذي أعبر و أدخل في الديكور
إذا تعبت أتوقف، أحاكي الناس، ألتقط صور
في هذه الرحلة لم أكن أستعمل الدراجة كل يوم
أتنقل من مكان إلى مكان في كل مكان أقضي
3 أو 4 أيام ثم أواصل لذلك دامت 35 يوم
في هذه الرحلة
لم يكن لي أو إطار جمعياتي أو ما شابهه
ذهبت بنفسي لوحدي
أوقفني البوليس 3 مرات ليتثبت من هويتي
و فتشوني مرّة ليتثبتو من ما حكيته
ثقبت العجلة في 3 مناسبات, أصلحها
بنفسي عادة لكن إلتجأت إلى الصلاح مرّة
أحاول دائما أن أسلك الطرق الفرعية
أتفادى الطرق السريعة و الواسعة
أسلك طرقا فارغة أغلب الأوقات
أتفادى السياقة في اليل أبدأ في الصباح
الباكر و أحاول الوصول آخر الصباح
بالنسبة للأكل
منعت نفسي من إستهلاك المواد المصنعة
كل ما هو خرج من مصنع أنا لا أستهلكه
ذلك لأسباب عديدة
لكن السبب الرئيسي هو أنني
كان لي تحدي أن لا أنتج فضلات لاعضوية
يعني كل ماهو بلاستيك بصفة عامة
المساند الرسمي لي كان العودة لدياري
التونسيّة ودوني بيها أحبابي و أقاربي
فيها البسيسة و برغل و زيت زيتونة
و هريسة عربي، و الرّب...
هنالك أيضا الغلال و الخضر
أهداها لي مظييفي و كل من خيمت عندهم
في الوسلاتية عشت مع أناس تنتج العسل
شاركتهم العمل فأهدوني القليل من العسل
التمر أقتنيه من النخلة مباشرة عندما خيمت
في الواحات الرمان و العنب أيضا
ذلك بائع خضار لم يقبل نقودي عندما
علم بقصتي، سلمني خضارا طبختها للعشاء
هنالك نباتات برّيّة مثل الطازيا، تنبت في
الصحراء لذيذة، كيف المعدنوس. طبخت بها
في تلك الصورة فلفل وجتده على قارعة الطريق
شاحنات نقل أسقطتها
إلتقت ثلاثة منها و طبختها و كانت ممتازة
بالنسبة للماء
لا أستهلك الماء الذي يباع في قوارير
من الحنفية من المقاهي أو المنازل في الطريق
أو من الآبار، أو الماجل أو العيون
أطبخ طعامي كل يوم على نار الحطب
أعد فطور صباح جيد
و في الغروب أطبخ عشاء جيد وسط النهار
آكل أشياء خفيفة، خضرا و غلال متوفرة
أغسل الأوعية بنفسي بالتراب
أو الرمل و القليل من الماء
كذلك أغسل ملابسي بنفسي، بالصابون الأخضر
المساند الرسمي للنظافة في الرحلة
إذن في آخر الرحلة
محصول الفضلات الغير عظويّة إلي أنتجتها
كان أقل من 10 غرامات
سأفتح معقفين لأبين سبب هذا التحدي
بالنسبة للڨحّاف، مشكل التلوّث
الذي نعيش فيه في زماننا
ليس مشكل تصرّف في الفضلات. بالنسبة لي
عندما أومي الزبالة في السلة تأخدها شاحنات
النظافة لكن في آخر المطاف تلقى في الطبيعة
ستحرق أو ستردم أو غير ذلك
لكن في جميع الحالات، ستلوث
إذن بالنسبة للڨحاف، المشكل
هو بالأساس مشكل إنتاج الفضلات
جيلنا ينتج آلاف المرات كميات من الفضلات
و مازلنا نزيد، هنلك نقص رهيب في الوعي
لذلك أردت أن أعيش تجربة أقضي فيها 5 أسابيع
أنشط فيها، أقوم بالكثير من الأشياء
أسافر، أتمتع... من دون أن أنتج زبالة
في آخر المطاف أنتجت 10 غرامات زبالة
كان معي 100 دينارالكثير قالولي أنه لا يكفي
لكن فالآخر لم أصرف إلا 9 دينارات 300 مليم
كيف? في الحقيقة لم تكن عملية تقشف. أبدا!
حكيت لكم كيف كان الأكل مالعولة وإلا الناس
إلي طيفتني تعطيني خضر و غلال من حديقتها
الماء: الحنفية و إلا مالبير و إلا مالماجل
النقل على الدراجة، السكنة كمبينڨ
العشاء نطبخو عالحطب
إذن في ٱخر المطاف لم أستحق للنقود أصلا
أستطيع أن أقلكم فيما صرفت النقود
5 دينارات لشراء إطار داخلي
في آخر الرحلة، بعد أن أصبحت بالية تماما
أصلحته بيه العجلة في مناسبة واحدة
عندما أضطررت أن أصلحها عند الصلّاح
دينار و نصف، في آخر الرحلة عندما
طالت اللحية وأصبح الناس يظنوني إرهابي
إشتريت آلة حلاقة و حلّقت اللحية
و 1800 ملم إستريت بها الخضار في 4 مناسبات
أشتري ب500 ملم ما يكفي لطبخ عشائي
موضوع الرحلة كان البحث
عن الحرّيّة و الأصالة و الجمال و الطبيعة
لذلك عندما أضع خيمتي، أبحث عن مكان جميل
مكان أصيل و طبيعي
في ضيعة أو في غابة أو في واحة
و إلا في الصحراء, تلك الصورة في
الصحراء في دوز أو في الكهوف في ڨابس
أماكن جميلة جدا
لما أخيم عند ناس أحاول الإندماج في أجوائهم
أعيش حياتهم أشارك في أنشطتهم و أعمل معهم
وجدت نفسي أعمل الحدادة
أصنع قوالب الطين في توزر
ألسق الخبز أعمل لعسل أزرع لشجر أجني لزيتون
و التمر أزرع الفول أرعى الماعز في الجبال
هذه كلها تجارب أصيلة
رمبا إن سافرت كسائح من غير الممكن عيشها
قابلت أيضا الكثير
من الأناس البسيطة و الأصيلة
كانو عندي معهم نقاشات عميقة و صريحة
خاصّة على واقعهم و مشاكلهم و حياتهم
و أحكي أيضا على فلسفتي أنا و أفكاري أنا
قابلت أيضا الكثير من الحيوانات الجميلة
آنسوني و تعلمت عنهم الكثير
شاهدت الكثير من مناظر طبيعية الجميلة،
خاصة مع شروق الشمس و غروبها، كل يوم
في تونس عندنا الكهوف، عندنا الصحراءعندنا
القرى البربريّة عندنا الشلّالات، الكانيون
إستمتعت كثيرا
حدثت عن هده التجربة يوم بيوم على الفايسبوك
في مثل هذا الوقت من السنة الفارطة
أنشر صورا و فيديوهات
و مع كل صورة أنشر تعليقا
و من يريد الفهم عليه أن يتابع
في بروفيل ڨحاف توجد تجارب كهذه أعيشها،
و توجد تعاليق أنشرها تعبر عن أفكار الڨحاف
توجد مجموعة مقولات و فيديو لأخرين
لكن يعبّرو على أفكار الڨحاف أنشرها كل يوم
و من يتابع يفهم الكثير من الأشياء
هناك تجربة أخرى عشتها الصيف الفارط
لن أتحدث عنها بالتفصيل اليوم
فقط سأعطيكم فكرة
هي في الأساس كانت فكرة ستاج تڨحيف
يعني تجربة أكون أنا موجود فيها رفقة مجموعة
من الأشحاص اللتي تابعتني على الفايسبوك
و نعيش تجربة تڨحيفة،
عيش على طريقة الڨحاف، مع بعضنا
سميناها "فستفال التڨحيف" أو "التڨحيفاست"
لن أخوض في التفاصيل
فقط أتيت بفيديو معي اليوم سيعرض لأول مرّة
رافقنا فريق
من وسيلة إعلام إسمها لكويد مدّة يوم
عاشو الأجواء
أخذو شهادات بعض المشاركين و شهادتي
و ان شاء الله تعبّر على الفستفال. شكرا
أنا مدمن بالحرّية
و غايتي أن أتعلم
و أن أحقق إمكانيّاتي كإنسان
أعتبر نفسي في رحلة بحث عن الحقيقة
مشروع "ڨحاف تونسي"
بدأته منذ تقريبا 4 سنوات
و هذا الصيف كان لي موعد مع أناس
تابعتني كثيرا عالفايسبوك
كي نعيش مع بعضنا تجربة التڨحيفاست،
فستفال التڨحيف
إسمي نادية لعتيري
أمل مديمغ
أحمد مرابط
إسمي محمد جهاد بوغانمي
صارو ثالثة دورات، كل وحدة دامت أسبوع
و شارك فيها تقريب عشرة مشاركين
أنا صديقة إلياس
أتابع في "ڨحاف تونسي" عالفايسبوك
أعجبت برحلاته في تونس
يلهمني كثيرا
الهدف من الفستفال، أن يعيش المشاركون تجربة
تساعدهم أن يفهمو كيف و لماذا بإمكاننا
أن نسافر أو نعيش على طريقة الڨحاف
إلياس يريد الوصول
إلى إكتفاء ذاتي في الغذاء
أخذت صورة لنفسي و أنا أزرع شجرة
و أرسلتها له
إنقّص من إستهلاك الماء و الضّو
هي تجربة، قلنا لما لا.
مدة أسبوع، لما لا نغير قليلا
كما رأتم في السبورة كتب "أصنع جوّك"
يعني بإمكانك أن تكون بناء
لست مظطرا لإنتاج شيء بذاته
نظام غدائي أساسه نباتات
تخيلت أنه من المستحيل
أن آكل فقط الخظر و الأعشاب
لكن بعدها عندما أكلت
وجدتها لذيذة، ليست سيئة
أنشطة إنتاجيّة، تثقيفيّة و ترفيهيّة
تم إقتراحها كل يوم على طول الأسبوع
وكان لنا تحدّي إستهلاك الموارد المتوفرة
مثل الماء و الكهرباء، بالكثير من مسؤوليّة
نعوض قدر الإمكان المنتوجات الصناعيّة
بمنتوجات محلّيّة أصيلة
و نجرب نظام غدائي أساسه النباتات
التي ننتجها و نحظرها بأيدينا
لو كنا واعين بأهميّة فكر الڨحاف هو حل
راديكالي لعديد المشاكل خاصة في البيئة
نعطي لأنفسنا الحرّية أن نمارس غرامنا
و نساهم به في المجتمع
يمكن أن تكون من دون وظيفة
لكن نافع في نفس الوقت
نعيش حياة بسيطة لكن فيها الكثير من الإنتاج
عملي، فني و فكري
بعيد عن المجتمع الإستهلاكي
و الحلم الأمريكي
هنا نحلم بالحرّية، بالإكتفاء الذاتي
بالحياة مع المجموعة و بالرجوع للطبيعة